january 3 2011
a day which will live infamously
holly partridge flax otherwise known as
holly otherwise otherwise known as a
living breathing angel is engaged to
another man
this is freaking me out i
okay let's just switch to the happy
video okay
no no no no let's push through we'll do
this today will either be the best or
the worst day of my life
holly gave aj an ultimatum he either
proposes by new years or they break up
now if she's engaged i'm gonna go crazy
and i'm gonna start attacking people if
she's not engaged in all i see i may
just burn this whole place to the ground
out of happiness either way i am going
to need some talking down and nobody
talks me down like myself in a video
talking me down michael i know what
you're thinking holly is engaged to
somebody else and you want to kill
yourself that may seem like a good idea
but it's not
it's not
sorry it sounded like you said it's snot
i'm so sorry
okay so killing yourself
i'm just thinking about snot
okay champagne happy
sponge sad to soak up my tears
gummy bears and gummy worms bear sat
worms happy come on erin
ukuleles happy sad something to break
chocolates for you job well done thank
you
two bottles of scotch well sad
and did you get the tickets i did i did
indeed
two front row center to paula poundstone
live in poughkeepsie holly's favorite i
hope she doesn't call us up on stage
that would suck
hey you think you could do my job better
i don't know what's your name michael
i'm really excited for michael either
way because if holly chooses to be with
him he will be so so happy and if not
he'll be avoiding the biggest mistake of
his life
happy happy happy happy
whoa whoa okay calm down three i'm
trying i said three
i'm trying wait a second are you
listening to music why shut that up
just go crazy for a little while
wow
you're good you're looking good
michael dance off
go
oh that's nice
me okay
oh yeah nice we're gonna calm down later
hey erin do we have any of those clips
that hold paper together staples
uh david wallace called oh he did what
did he say he heard you made a big
splash at the meeting oh my god that was
so mean what i just said and i didn't
mean it was kevin and meredith put me up
to it
okay
i'm gonna kill you
you did this
no i was just checking yes i did yes yes
why won't you like him what is there to
like he's just
he's a weird little
skeevy guy with no waist why do you care
whether we like him or not i i care if
you like him why i'm not your father
all right
okay go to your room
what go to your room young lady
um
i'm not going to my room
you listen to me
you listen good you are not
to see that boy
anymore you listen to me you are not to
tell me what to do as long as you are
living under this roof you are going to
do what i said i hate your roof oh do
not raise your voice to me i'll reason i
won i'll raise the roof i will pull this
car over i hate it i hate your
car see oscar
if you break that girl's heart i will
kill you
it's just figure speech but seriously if
you break that girl's heart i will
literally kill you and your entire
family gabe just go and have fun with
air but not too much fun
that girl's gonna turn my hair gray
who's hungry what is that it's ants on a
log michael would always have me bring
them in at 2 30 and say who's hungry oh
uh i'm fine thank you though do you want
me to spin you in your chair and make
you dizzy why would i want to do that
it's a thinking technique all the top
executives do it it keeps the brain
moving and uh spinning brain is a
working brain for now i'm just gonna
go back to work here oh sure yeah thank
you well
oh it smells good in here
sure does okay we have your space heater
your humidifier your dehumidifier your
fan your foot fan and your food
dehydrator erin
what about my keyboard
so good to be home
have a little bossa nova
[Music]
oh my god
what according to the internet the
tallest man in the world is chinese so
much for keeping our secrets up high
what's america gonna do i know what
we're gonna do we're gonna put our best
minds on it
god
ugh
erin
oh
sorry i thought everyone was gone no no
i was just watching cookie monster
finally downloaded you mind if i sit
down
what some
ah i can't trust andy anymore oh
yeah
i'm sorry about that i feel i'm sorry i
caused that though it's andy's fault
well yeah yes so but i still feel sorry
oh
you know what i wouldn't worry about
angela she's
she doesn't hold a candle to you erin
she's
old enough to be your mom for one thing
and she's
like three feet tall
and she wears pioneer women clothing
and and i don't think she's ever pooped
and andy you know come on andy his butt
looks big in those khakis
i like this butt
you said butt
you tricked me
[Laughter]
oh no you'd love oh
this this guy in my neighborhood tom
more
this is him
hey
sometimes telling someone something is
hard
well at least somebody made her happy on
secretary's day
hey mr scott what you gonna do what you
gonna do with my country and country hey
what are you gonna do please start
chicken
15
lives
i destroyed 15 young lives today no
yes
no there's financial aid
um
they could join the army or the navy
like 12.
the principal told me that
90 of scott's tots are on track to
graduate and that's 35 higher than the
rest of the school so
i think that if you hadn't made that
promise a lot of them would have dropped
out which
is something to think about i think
i think you're doing a great job
really
what do you want from this job provided
the company doesn't go out of business
well i've always wondered what it might
be like to be an accountant really yes
but i'm terrible at math so
you know when i hired kevin
he was actually applying for a job in
the warehouse
seriously yeah
i just sort of had a feeling about him
i have a feeling about you too
hey mr scott what you gonna do what you
gonna do make our dreams come true
hey
what are you gonna do
what you're gonna do make us dream come
true yeah what if we all get together
and help each other and hire a new guy
and then we all kill him but first we
take out like a hundred thousand dollar
life insurance policy i bet you guys
like that idea don't you
i think that's what they're doing to me
i can't prove it but i wanted to see
their faces when i said it
i learned nothing
i don't know what that was
you